all right we can all breathe a giant
sigh of relief over the crisis at the
border
everything's better you guys vice
president kamala harris claims she's
finally taking things seriously
when she's not blaming the surge of
migrants on climate change
watch this is a priority for our nation
and a role that i take very seriously we
are focused on addressing
both the acute factors and the root
causes
of migration there are the long-standing
issues
the root causes and i'm thinking of
corruption
violence and poverty the lack of
economic opportunity
the lack of climate adaptation and
climate resilience
the lack of good governance it's amazing
because it's easy to grow drugs
even when there is a climate lack of
resilience
juan so she's talking about corruption
violence and poverty
as root causes one these are not root
causes
these are actually effects you can sit
around for years
and stroke your chin and claim you're
getting to the heart of the issues by
talking about root causes but she's not
really talking about any root causes
here
well i'm trying to understand make sure
i get what you're saying because it
seems to me like she's 100
right you know just on the face of it
when people you know feel like you know
they're not safe and
because of violence in their country
when they feel there's no
future for their families uh you know
why else would they decide they're gonna
walk a hundred miles with an uncertain
future and drag their children along
with a backpack
that's that those are desperate people
and
of course when you have the environment
degraded and people can't
farm can't rely on us
they're going to be desperate lots of
farming and i don't
i think what you see right
that there's plenty of farming because
they're growing plenty of drugs
and the governments are enriching
themselves go ahead
oh what i was going to say is i think
that what we see going on right now
in places like venezuela the level of
violence and disruption
it may i that's why i say to me this is
pretty obvious you have desperate people
and she is speaking to a root cause
and trying to allow and speak the idea
that if we can make those places better
and safer
it helps not only those people to stay
at home it helps
us as americans because oftentimes those
are our neighbors
they are neighbors and they are in need
and they're in very desperate situations
i will absolutely agree with you on that
uh the root cause is the drug war so
greg vice president harris is visiting
milwaukee wisconsin miliwake a lovely
city
to talk about infrastructure when it's
the immigration system
that is crumbling why is she so
unserious about this issue
i think we're kind of figuring out that
she might not be a serious person
at all i think they i think that they
were counting on a learning curve where
she would be moving
more quickly to take over the job and
then in the next
year i don't think they're going to be
able to do it the issue here is why they
talk about climate change
and these root causes is because you
can't fix it not in your lifetime
they don't expect her to do anything but
repeat these platitude and his uh
catchphrases that we've heard for years
from the dams the dems have two clubs
in their golf bag to beat you with race
and climate they don't have to rely on
data
so instead what they do is they go well
if you don't if you want to be uh
you know harder on immigration tougher
on immigration uh you're a cold-hearted
bigot
who hates the earth that's what you do
because then you don't have to actually
talk about facts
remember the game six degrees of kevin
bacon where you can link every actor to
kevin baker a great game
now we have six degree with their two
games six degrees of the climate
apocalypse
or six degrees of hitler you're either
gonna get one or the other
from a democrat they're either gonna try
to link something to global warming or
try to link something to white supremacy
because they are scared to death of
actual
data so when you're talking about
actual crises and i would say dana that
what's happening on the southern border
what's happening in these countries
both of them the root causes and the
immediate surge both crises
so you put the vice president in charge
of that
like we saw with the pandemic crisis
there was an
urgency there there was a need to get
vaccines made
and and have them quickly pass through
the fda
so you could save lives that's the kind
of urgency that we need to see
on the border uh when are we going to
see that what will it take
um well i would imagine uh and just to
be very cynical
uh when their poll numbers crater to the
point that they realize that uh
it's going to hurt them in the election
i mean that's probably when
you might see something the interesting
thing about the climate thing is
it is a global issue right they call it
global climate change but what is the
difference between the people who are
fleeing the places where
they are living and those places that
are not having anybody try to flee
um it is rule of law and governance
that's the big difference and
uh you know obviously there are some
countries are going to be able to adapt
uh slowly but
to greg's point it's absolutely right
and the administration admits this
no matter what we try to do we are not
going to be able to solve a global
problem
and china is building a coal-fired power
plant a week
that's just like not happening so it
doesn't matter but the other thing here
that i would just want to point out very
quickly is
there's another huge crisis in el
salvador and the administration kind of
finds themselves a little bit twix in
between because what should they do
in el salvador the strong man there has
decided he's going to
replace judges on the supreme on its own
equivalent of the supreme court
and put in friends there and that way
that he'll get
decisions that are more in his favor and
now the administration has said you know
an independent judiciary is very
important
really well that's great to know because
so hopefully that means that your idea
of court packing on the left is going to
be chucked out the window yes absolutely
that is
that is a different form of court
packing uh with the same results
so um jesse i'm just trying to tap into
your mind
before the 2020 midterms uh do you
do you see this administration returning
to
a robust wall along the southern border
and some of the
migrant protection protocols
reintroduced
maybe about 25 percent just for window
dressing
but kennedy i think we're missing the
point it's not just climate change
anymore it's a new phrase
climate adaption and climate resilience
we are getting into the
intersectionality
phraseology now juan
i mean if it's really about the climate
is she going to argue that
the sea levels are rising so high that
coastal villages are fleeing to higher
ground
because that's not happening and that
would be a lie or is she saying that
it's now 10 degrees hotter
in guatemala and people are fleeing
north to
colder climates also not happening but
if it is just explain it like that greg
nailed it
climate change and racism is just a lazy
deflection from having to actually argue
on the substance this whole thing was
triggered
by biden's policies and his rhetoric by
promising amnesty
and asylum and entitlements but we love
cocaine in this
doesn't come in from country anymore it
comes in through panama
and they have the panamanian the
corridor that's the biggest drug highway
runs right up through panama all through
mexico and the drug cartels
just wreak havoc and the a lot of
violence there it destabilizes
a very tender region and it's not just
cocaine they're involved in they're
involved in avocados
tourism people say on the left oh i like
my coffee fair trade
i don't want these big corporations
involved in my coffee okay
well who do you think controls the
peasants that are making your
fair trade coffee it's the cartels yeah
narcotics coffees cartel coffee
that's exactly what it is so if you if
you really want to do something
it's not climate resilience it's cartel
resilience
that's absolutely right jesse that's a
great point we should have fair trade
cocaine
and we should have it grown and
manufactured assaulted
in these united states well said
starbucks it is
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else